now I did mention in period zero today
but while we were talking about
properties the reason for me to gather
them into groups like this is so that
you can hang them sort of on your mind
is like it's not just a bunch of random
things made you've gotta sit but at the
same time these properties clearly
overlap so I'm going to give you angle
properties now but we'll come back to
other properties that also clearly
involve angles so it's not like these
the only ones at all so I'm going to
give you a couple of really nice lovely
properties and one of the great things
about this is that I expect many of you
will draw a diagram just like line but
the beautiful thing about circles and
geometry in general is that if it's a
property or a theorem it's true whatever
kind of circle that you draw whatever
combination of particular intervals so
long as there is a kind the category of
intervals I'm going to mention I'm not
doing all the same thing so for instance
in your first circle what I'd like you
to do is draw for me a diameter any
diameter you like is an infinite number
of diameters in a circle so pick one
here's a diameter and what you'll notice
excuse me is it a diameter is just a
special kind of chord right I suppose
you could define one of the ways you
could define a diameter is it's the
longest cord you can possibly draw in a
circle do you agree with that
like you've got to join two points in
this conference no chord can possibly be
longer than the diameter okay the chord
the diameter blocks off two segments
that happen to be both equal so there's
no minor segment or major segment in
this case they're both the same size
what I want you to do is pick a point
any point on the circumference anywhere
you like literally anywhere and make it
different to the person next to you okay
so I'm going to put my point up here
okay here comes the magic now where no
matter where you've drawn your point if
you now form a triangle
which joins up the end of your diameter
to your choice chosen point so you're
going to join up the ends of your
diameter to your point join them up and
create a triangle and you should notice
something quite amazing about your
triangle and look at the one next to you
as well
of your friend no matter where you have
drawn your triangle or picked your point
what kind of a triangle have you drawn
you've drawn a right-angled triangle you
cannot escape it no matter where you put
this point you can move him around in
fact I'm going to demonstrate an
interesting property down here no matter
where you draw it you can draw a whole
series of them if you like
no matter where you've drawn them you'll
get a right-angled triangle again and
again and again so the name of this
property is because the segments that
you drew off was actually not just any
segment
it's a semicircle it's exactly heart the
semicircle the name of this property is
the angle in a semicircle is a right
angle or 90 degrees is even faster to
right than saying a right angle okay
angle in a semicircle is 90 degrees okay
so how we're going to prove it it's a
delightful proof it's so quick I'm going
to show it to you you'll get the essence
of and then I'll ask you to prove it
like formally later on okay let's give
this thing some names shall we Center
the circle what do you call it
Oh take your consistency let's call this
diameter something like say a bee and
you've got a third point up there so
let's call him see okay now as we
noticed with our proofs earlier this
morning often a construction is very
important and in circle geometry more
than anywhere else you will need to add
constructions onto your diagram when
you're required to make proofs that are
not there already so here's what I'm
going to add on the radius OC can you
join that up for me the radius of OC
there we go now once you see that I
wonder how your brain is ticking over
remember what we're trying to prove what
we required to prove is that or what
we're aiming to proves the ACB is 90
degrees always 90 degrees no matter what
okay what kinds of shapes have I created
by joining up this radius OC what kind
of shapes do you see I see triangles and
they're not just any triangles what kind
of triangles are they they're all
isosceles why is that there's a reason
they're all radii OC was a radius a OS
of radius B they're all good right so in
fact maybe you want to even mark them in
as such so having made this pair of
isosceles triangles what are the kinds
of things that you know
isosceles triangles you know you've got
a pair of equal slides what else you've
got a pair of equal angles which of
those do you think is going to be more
useful to me and try to prove this
probably off of the angles right this is
a statement about an eagle okay they're
all statement about angles so therefore
where are the equal angles we draw in
our diagram I've drawn my diagram so
it's quite easy to see for instance in
AOC which are the equal angles you can
name the country come on they have dance
a ACO this small one up here and CA oh
the ops one okay so we could label these
we call these both alpha for instance I
will do this for me in a second in fact
I'm going to ask you to do this for me
in a second but what I'm trying to model
for you here is you're trying to look
first you're trying to see first and
then you're trying to communicate second
so we would do a proper like formal
proof of this okay but first it's
important that you see where you're
going so you can have a path through
there's one isosceles triangle and then
the other you can see these two are
going to be the base angles as it were
okay so I'm going to call their beta and
beam up do you need me to tell you what
to do next what could you do who can see
it remember what you try to get to
you're trying to show that ACB is 90
degrees which in the scheme I've just
named a few things that alpha plus beta
right alpha plus beta now keeping in
mind that all of the alphas are being is
different I really hope a fizzer beings
are all different right this is true
whatever alpha and beta are
independently but both of them together
has to add up to 90 and just have a look
at your diagram you can see it right so
how we should what do we know about
alpha beta we don't very much but we
know enough what do we know Eric what do
you see
that's all good
there's the best suggestion yes yes okay
so you're saying for instance this guy
here this guy here is equal to 180 minus
2 alpha is that what you just said this
one is a hundred anyone's two alpha so
you want to like slice that in half is
that what you're doing okay all right
well it's not I'm going to actually
disagree with you answer there's any
wrong things you can do so long as you
know you're not violating the rules of
geometry but there are quick ways and
there are efficient ways and there are
less efficient ways to get to you know
our angle I'm going to suggest you
actually done it especially things at
all you can but there's a way to get
there which is I've done everything no
constructions more required if there's a
faster way where you can pull yeah what
do you got go ahead tell me what you're
done did you go through these angles it
me or did you do something else okay you
can this is fine like I said I I think
it's not true to say that's wrong it's
just another way here's the way I like I
think it's nice and simple and doesn't
require any fancy appealing to other
angles you got all the angles you need
okay have a look at this angle here one
angle two angles three angles in one big
shape right what's the big shape it's a
triangle right 1 2 3 angles they add up
to in a triangle they add up to 2 alpha
plus 2 beta that's that's all of those
angles all added up together right is
equal to 180 degrees and there's of
course a reason for this you can go
ahead and you can state the reasons but
I'm their anti anti they're three lines
who is good
two lines is a little better okay so
this is what I mean circles are
beautiful objects okay there's image
and wonderful shapes sort of tucked in
there that you can take advantage of
okay so I'm going to leave it to you to
complete that proof formally all right